my mom had a uh a reading with a woman
in Manhattan who was a very prestigious
psychic in her own Rank and she didn't
do what would be considered House
Parties which is like take out
Tupperware bring in psychic and um she
agreed to do that if she could meet me
so like there was this very weird moment
when my mom came home and said August
whatever you know you're going to be
here and I'm went where am I going I'm
15 I go where am I going to be and she
said well this woman Lydia clar is
coming and she wants to meet you and I
was like who's LD clar and she said oh
she's a psychic and I remember like why
does the psychic want to meet me like
that was like never had happened before
and um and she said she agreed to come
to the house and she never does that so
I took her up on the opportunity but her
one caveat was that she wanted to meet
me me I meet you and I was like so I'm
like bait like I'm the bait to get her
here and my mom laughed and she goes
she's really really good and I laughed
and I was like okay and then I forgot
about it and then she reminded me like
hey make make sure that you hear on
whatever the date was and then the woman
came and I met her and she was a lovely
lady and she kind of like you know I
guess she looked psychic the way she
like you know the way she looked for me
and um she read I want to say she read
like 17 people that day yeah she read a
lot of people there was a lot of people
that my mom got to come to have these
like really mini readings and um I think
she had read about seven people and then
my grandmother had come down from the
room crying and that pissed me off cuz I
was like that's my grandma like I'm like
what did this woman say to you to make
you upset and she said I'm not crying
cuz I'm sad I'm crying cuz I'm happy I
didn't really care my grandmother was
crying like what did the stranger say to
my grandmother in her house that's
disrespectful and rude so she told my
grandmother that her husband was
standing next to her and gave her all
these in all these messages um from my
deceased grandfather who I did not know
and one of the things was she got her
name he got his name how he passed um a
whole bunch of things and then um I said
to my grandma Lego grandma she said his
name was Tony and is his name is Anthony
so um I go Grandma you were introduced
to her as Mrs es bazito you don't get
more Italian than Esposito it's like
Smith in Italy right I'm like I don't
think it's a big stretch that somewhere
there's going to be a Tony in the
Esposito family and without skipping a
beat my grandmother looked at me and
said if you don't believe that the
grandfather that you don't know love me
more than life itself and is still with
me sounds like a you issue like that's
your problem she goes how would that
woman know that he was buried with a
mandolin I didn't know he was buried
with a mandolin and I was like why was
he be with a mandolin apparently used to
play the mandolin so I didn't even know
that so then I didn't take that at face
value I went back to the list of people
that Lydia read before my grandmother to
see which person on that list she could
have extrapolated that information from
and then give it to the old lady in the
house none of the people that went
before my grandmother were family like
none of them would know that so I was
like how the hell would she know that so
then I said well my mom knows her maybe
my mom told her maybe that came up in my
mom's conversation like so I'm looking
I'm always logical I'm always looking
for the logic of it and then that's what
got me to go for a reading I wanted to
prove to my family that she wouldn't be
able to read me and she wasn't going to
be able to get anything out of me so my
intention was I would sit opposite her
and I would just do the like the
following for those that are just
listening he's not doing anything
exactly straight face straight face like
I'm going to give her nothing yeah and
then I sat with her and she took my high
school ring at the time and she kind of
like put it to her forehead looked down
and never looked at me and then just
started
talking and um that put me on my path
she was spot on she say what did she say
to you she told me that I had highly
this is where it gets all weird she told
me I had highly involved beings of white
and gold light and they were ready to
work with me and that I was going to
change the way millions of people looked
at her
field I was I was 15 she could have so
you were a non-believer so this this
seemed like a no this seemed like she
said she landed her spaceship in the
backyard and she take me for a spin when
we're done that's so she told you you
had this power this is you were going to
this is the path you were going to from
that reading to when did did you have an
experience so from that reading which by
the way she ended it with stuff that was
like accurate but I didn't know how how
accurate it was for about a week she
gave me outcomes to circumstances that
nobody in my family knew about nobody in
my family knew about and they played out
in a way that made me go holy crap like
this is like this is uncomfortable and I
say uncomfortable because I didn't see
it as cool I saw it as a violation oh
that's how you feel right mhm I saw it
as a violation and I was like oh I don't
like this I'm like this woman walked
around my life and then new stuff and
then wait a minute she had like insights
about what was going to happen with
these people don't like this so it
wasn't like oh I'm so psychic let me go
learn about it it was more like I feel
like I got energetically robbed and I
want to put a security system in is this
possible and that sent me to the public
library and that's where my life really
started to change because in
1985 there were no new age books or
psychic books it was under the occult
section so I would sit on the floor of
the public library and I was embarrassed
to check the books out because it had
the word ult I didn't know what that
meant which just means hidden secret
Arcane knowledge right but back then it
sounded like cult so I sat and read
every day as much as I could after like
high school and I learned that there
were people writing books in the 30s 40s
50s and 60s they were folks like Carl
Young and some of the you know the
forefathers of the United States that
were Masons who all have meta had
metaphysical belief systems um I learned
about you know Madam blaty from Russia I
learned about Casey in in in Virginia I
learned about Jee Dixon in astrology but
I learned about reincarnation numerology
psychometry tarot I learned a lot in a
very very short period of time and then
after I literally exhausted everything
that was at the library I went to a
local bookstore and it was a Walden
bookstore um on Glen Cove Road in Long
Island for the folks that know the area
and I walked to the back of that store
again a cult section and the way that
the books the shelves were they were
like on an ark right so there were like
very sparsely shelves not a lot of new
material was there but they had tarot
cards and a deck of cards literally fell
off in front of me like I if I didn't
see it I wouldn't believe it but I'm
telling you it happened and the lady
that was running the store she was like
on the middle like shelf and she like
looked over and looked at me and she
went hm clearly you're supposed to buy
those so I bought them and I was like
this is ridiculous I felt like I was
doing like a drug deal I don't want
anybody like to like see me with these
in my house you know so I take them in
my house and I'm I'm looking at the
little white book that comes with the 78
cards that tells you what the cards mean
and how to read them and then that
Sunday my cousin my there was always
like 20 people in my grandma's house cuz
she had 11 kids they had kids they had
kids and if you knew my grandmother she
was like Sophia from The Golden Girls if
you didn't show up on Sunday there was
hell to pay so we always had a house
full of people so my cousin came and I
was like hey can I can I like try
something for you and she went sure I
was like I want I want to try to like
read your cards so I did I did the what
the book said I looked at the cards and
I you know they kind of like told me a
story or I you know kind of put things
together in the way that I interpreted
it and then like a week or two later she
said hey you going to be your grandma's
on Sunday and I went yeah why are you
coming and she's like yeah she's like I
want you to do my cars again I was like
Florence please I go I have no idea what
I'm doing I go I'm just messing around
with this and she's like yeah well mess
around again cuz everything you said was
going to happen happened I was like yeah
but I'm sure it's just a coincidence and
she said no there's no way that you
would have known a couple of those
things and I didn't even tell you that
you're right she goes and then they
happened and she goes and can I bring
five friends and that's literally how it
started